hello
to all you freedom lovers out there
and those of you who are freedom haters
but watch this show that just so that
you can tweet angry things at me
how's it going people and thanks for the
views it is november
16 2020 we are just one day shy of two
weeks from that election that we had
and we still don't really have results
we've got
the ap saying we've got results and
we've got cnn saying results
but no results have been certified we
don't have results in
like a resulting sort of way if you care
about the system
that's supposed to tell us how
everything works we've got
news organizations that have told us
something has happened there's a lot
going on in the world
as you guys know i was in dallas last
week it was my first
trip since lockdown began i actually got
on an airplane
and i traveled to another state another
state that is a little more freedom
loving texas
than the state of california that i live
in i had dinner
with friends we hugged we shared food
there was it was you know they had the
brussels sprouts with the spoon and you
know my theory about
sharing the spoon at thanksgiving it's
like you know if there's a big thing of
potatoes big thing uh you know stuffing
brussels sprouts whatever it may be
you share the spoon it's okay it's okay
um
so we did that had a great time there's
a lot of good things going on that i'll
have some updates for you guys in the
next couple weeks but some interesting
stuff happening
uh with the blaze down in dallas and and
a ton of great stuff happening
uh with locals and if you don't know
what we're doing with locals check out
reubenreport.com
and uh and of course as i tweeted out
this morning if you
thought things have been bananas it's
gonna be a super bananas week you can
just kind of feel it sometimes i wake up
and i can just kind of feel like oh
today's not going to be too crazy or
this week is kind of going to be okay
and then you know you always get
surprised of course along the way
but i just have a sense that this week
is going to be
super ultra pasteurized bananas it's
just it's just going to be nutty you can
kind of feel it already
so we are doing an extra story today you
guys know i like to do two or three
stories but i
said to my guys about a half hour ago
we've got to bump in a fourth story
because of all the craziness or talk a
little bit
about obviously the election we're going
to talk about covid we're going to talk
about this this bill maher
video a guy who i i used to admire a ton
who was one of my first inspirations in
all this thing but i think he's lost the
plot a little bit
of course i'd be happy to have that
conversation with him and then we're
going to talk about
one of the transition members of the joe
biden
president-elect office it's not really
in office
who in a piece in the washington post
about a year ago
was calling to end free speech no more
first amendment so we'll
get to all of that but let's start with
what happened this weekend because
there was some interesting stuff that
happened and i'm going to try to present
something to you now
that is an honest take on what happened
now this is not
what you're going to get as i always say
from cnn
or the new york times okay and i was
even tweeting that and many other people
were actually tweeting that over the
weekend
so there was a mega million march in dc
it is unclear how many people showed
whether it was a million people or
several hundred thousand people
but there were thousands and thousands
of people there were
there are videos and pictures of just
streets absolutely lined up
with trump supporters trump flags
american flags
there was virtually no violence during
the day
people were happy they were cheering on
america
people of all walks of life and all
colors and all of that stuff that we're
all so sick
of talking about that gets jammed down
our throats by the mainstream media
every day
but of course the the day did not end
that way when the blm
antifa people showed up but i want to
first show you and i guarantee
that this is not on cnn today okay
guarantee
this is not on cnn today this is the
national anthem
uh being sung by some of the trump
supporters at the magamillion march and
it's actually quite heartwarming and
lovely
take a look
[Music]
great
[Applause]
i mean tell me that is not spectacular
you know we used to do that sort of
thing at baseball games and basketball
games and football games when we used to
go to games with
audiences but we don't do that anymore
apparently
and i mean just look
beautiful thousands of people singing
the national anthem
and they're not doing it in the name of
racism or misogyny
or homophobia or anything else they're
doing it
in the name of we love america and
for hours and hours throughout the day
there were good people out there
expressing
their right which is their their
god-given right enshrined in the
constitution in the bill right the
united states
to use their free expression and their
free speech to stand up
for what they believe in they did not
burn down stores they did not loot
anything they did not attack
people in restaurants or attack police
officers or stop cars on the road or
anything else they did it
the right way now you may not agree with
exactly what they were saying you may
not agree with what they feel about the
election results or anything else but
the point is these are people
organizing with doing something that is
the most american
thing that you can do and doing it
peacefully the way it's supposed to be
done
and not the way the other side does it
even though we're always told these are
the bad guys right so what the media
does
is they'll ignore you know hundreds of
thousands of people out there singing
the national anthem and doing it
uh peacefully and then they'll focus on
the violent part so then let's show you
we have four videos here
uh we're just packing this into about 50
seconds we just cut them up
uh of just random violent events once
antifa
and blm showed up and then of course
you'll see that most of this happened
once the sunset so take a look
[Applause]
out of here
[Applause]
all right so that's just a tiny sampling
of the videos of the day they were all
going across twitter now the media will
frame these things if you're going to
see any of these videos it will be
framed somehow the trump supporters
were attacking people although they'll
mostly ignore it because so many of the
videos are so
obvious or they might selectively edit
it so that someone
who responds to an attack will look like
the attacker
and the rest of it this again is why the
mainstream media is crumbling and
and deservingly so i i quickly did a
scan of
most of the cnn anchors twitter feeds
yesterday and somehow
didn't didn't tweet out anything about
the peaceful stuff and then didn't tweet
out anything of the violent stuff
because it didn't fit the narrative
right
now there's many more videos there's
there's people attacking children
attacking elderly people all sorts of
craziness
just think about it this way do you
think any of the trump supporters who
showed up
with american flags trump flags all
those things who were all being peaceful
do you think
that they were thinking okay the night
the way this night should end
is we're gonna start wrecking havoc on
the city and attacking people in
restaurants and everything else i mean
you saw in that compilation we just
showed
i mean people that were literally
sitting at restaurants outside having
fireworks thrown at them windows broken
and the rest of it
these are not the trump supporters it
doesn't make the trump supporters right
about everything or necessarily right
about the election
that's a separate issue altogether
antifa
and blm but but in this case mostly
antibody these are
masked thugs who are here to to create
violence and
why is it that the democrats why is it
that mainstream media is completely
unable
to talk about this honestly thus leaving
me and other people other internet
people
to talk about this it's it's absolutely
bananas
goes to the reality war that i'm
constantly talking about and these
people
in effect are domestic terrorists
imagine if you were sitting there
really put yourself in the situation
you're sitting at a restaurant outside
and people just start attacking you they
have no idea what you believe
but it doesn't even matter they are
attacked they are trying to burn down
everything
and we don't have honest political
leaders especially on the left
who will who will deal with it if
anything they they're enjoying
the violence because it allows them to
frame it somehow
that the evil trump people did it anyway
i know we could probably do stories like
this every freaking day because this
stuff
never stops i mean the amount of stuff
we see out of portland every day where
they're actually going into residential
neighborhoods and harassing people now
it's just it's just kind of endless but
it's important
for you to know this and to see the
truth so that when you get
into the arguments and the fights with
people who will tell you that trump has
roving gangs of white supremacists out
there
well no he doesn't and the freaking
proud boys were out there
and were they pro were they out there in
honor of white supremacy awful lot of
black and latino uh people out there in
honor of white supremacy i mean the
whole thing is
so backwards they're telling you not to
see what you can see with your own eyes
and then to see things that don't exist
it
actually is nutty but speaking of nutty
how about a transition right there
speaking of nutty dr fauci uh has uh
a new interview that he did on cnn and
he said that masks are still going to be
necessary after getting the vaccine now
let's not forget
uh pfizer said that they have a 90
vaccine
last week and then everybody was
discussing how it will be distributed
trump did a kind of funny thing
basically saying that you know new
york's not going to get it unless cuomo
wants it
and cuomo said he didn't want something
coming from trump so then it's a good
play of getting like the people of new
york actually upset at cuomo
uh now apparently another drug company
has another vaccine
so there's interesting things happening
on the ground okay
we know this to be true but listen to
fouchy
and and let's discuss after you know i
would recommend that that's not the case
i would recommend you have an
added area of protection obviously
with a 90 plus percent effective vaccine
you could feel much more confident
but i would recommend to people to not
abandon
all public health measures just because
you've been vaccinated because
even though for the general population
it might be 90 to 95
effective you don't necessarily know for
you how effective it
is so when i get vaccinated which i hope
to
when when it becomes to get vaccinated
i'm not going to abandon completely
public health measures i could feel more
relaxed
and and essentially not having the
stringency of it
that we have right now but i think
abandoning it completely would not be a
good idea
okay so there there's a couple things
there now first off i'm not here to bash
fauci
okay now he's a he's a government
scientist in effect and
as we know it's not like these days this
isn't like
you know back in the 60s we're going to
the moon and we get the best government
you know the best scientists become
government scientists who are all the
innovators and everything else most of
them work
in in private enterprise now so but i'm
not here to bash
fauci and fauci's made some mistakes and
he's he's done some things right and
he's
kind of flipped on some things and
everything else nobody's perfect this is
why i also don't get crazed
about all the politicians mucking
something up every now and again because
nobody's perfect and hindsight is 20 20
and all of those things
but what he said there is that the the
vaccine will be 90 to 95
effective okay we also know that right
now
uh coronavirus covid has something like
a 99
recovery rate we know that elderly
people and people with pre-existing
conditions get sick
so at what time is it enough at what
time is it to say okay we don't have to
wear masks anymore we don't have to
social distance and everything else
and that's why you really got to
remember this one part if nothing else
when they're telling you when the biden
administration is saying hey we're going
to do a federal lockdown
why keep outsourcing all of your
decisions
your thanksgiving plans your christmas
plans jake tapper was on cnn
yesterday talking about canceling
christmas okay
literally find the video i'm not making
this [ __ ] up um
why would we keep outsourcing all of our
personal decisions and who we're gonna
have in our house and everything else
to these people this is bad news just
because
someone that is a an authoritative
source at some level
says something these are the same people
who were telling us
two weeks to flatten the curve that was
nine
months ago so something is rotten in
stink town
you got me something something ain't
right here so i am not saying
that when you get the vaccine and as he
said it's 90 to 95
that doesn't necessarily mean you run
around and you start sneezing on people
and licking
phone poles and and whatever else there
is but it's like
we do also need to start opening up we
also need to start living normally and i
think that this
this constant push to now tell us how
we can celebrate thanksgiving whether we
can celebrate
christmas while at the same time we know
that
uh here in california gavin newsom our
governor who's telling people you can't
have more than 10 people
over for thanksgiving he was at a party
with at least 12 other people at french
laundry which is one of the most
expensive restaurants
in the in wine country in sonoma napa
area it's like 150 bucks a plate nor in
normal times you can't
get reservations there for months we
tried to go once and we could not get
reservations
but so but that's what they do you know
when you see the
the mayor mayor lightfoot she's a real
piece of work in chicago
and she's out on the street without a
mask and chuck schumer is out on a
street without
and all of these people they act one way
and they want you to act another way
so it's like why should we trust that
layer of people that just want to
control us and i really think we need to
think about this more and
and for those of you that watch i i get
some emails about this people say dave
you're telling people not to go out you
know to go out there without mass blah
blah
i'm not telling you to do anything i'm
telling you you must do what is right
for you
and your family and by extension your
local community that it should be bottom
up
not top down because it seems to me that
no matter how much authority
the more authority that we give them the
more they want to take
which is why and find the videos of me
saying it guys back in may when they
were saying
uh in california we're going to lock
down to august august 1st then we'll
reopen you can find the videos and be
saying i guarantee we don't
open in august first because that's what
they do they just keep moving the goal
post moving the goal post moving the
goal posts
and in many ways i still think this has
far more to do with destroying the
economy and keeping people afraid
and afraid of rallying because they
don't like which way the rallies are
going right now because the rallies are
for
trump and let's not forget also that
last saturday when the ap
announced that biden was the
president-elect you had people all over
new york hundreds and thousands of
people celebrating mask lists
the great video of these girls sharing a
bottle of champagne
nobody talked about covid spreading
there wasn't a super
super spreader event but when the trump
people get out there it is i mean that's
why kovid and politics and the election
and all these things they've become
like this twisted thing that are that
are
they're just tangled and they can't be
untangled
and do do what is right for you and i
think if we all start doing what's right
for us
that we might have some better uh we
might have some better results
at least at the personal level in your
own personal life uh okay
let's talk about uh bill maher now bill
maher
as you know has been basically
the sort of standard bearer of the left
i would say for the last almost 30 years
in america like he's the most
public outspoken lefty but i would for
the most part
call bill maher an old school liberal
bill maher and i agree on most of the
things especially on
on the free speech stuff where i would
say i differ from him now is that i
definitely am more conservative
economically
and in terms of states rights and all of
that kind of stuff where he's just kind
of gone in on on the big government
stuff so what i see the flaw in bill's
thinking
is that he's always railing against the
government they're all corrupt they're
all evil blah blah blah his answer is
always
oh but just tax everybody more and more
government programs and everything else
that's very consistent with the flaw
that i see on by most lefty's thinking
but that being said
i i like bill maher i've met him once or
twice and chatted with him i was
supposed to be on the show for my book
and then it got cancelled because of
covet and then they asked me
one other time but that hasn't happened
i don't really care anymore the show
kind of feels
feels old like it used to be sort of a
gatekeeper show it kind of doesn't feel
that way anymore
but all of that being said i think bill
bill is basically the last sort of
mainstream
relatively sane voice on the left okay
and often he's just repeating things
that i was saying a year or two ago
um and i don't think that's a
coincidence well anyway he on his show
this week
he did a little piece calling out the
woke democrats the the really crazy
lefties and the identity politics people
and all that
let's take a look and then we will
analyze but democrats were supposed to
flip the senate and didn't
supposed to flip state legislatures not
a one
and they lost seats in the house in a
year that was so much about making
people aware of racism
their share of minority votes went down
the message to democrats from so much of
the country seems to be we don't like
trump but we still can't bring ourselves
to vote for you
if crackerjack was made of popcorn and
dog [ __ ]
and half the people threw out the
popcorn
popcorn should want to know why
liberals can either write off half the
country as irredeemable or they can ask
what is it about a d
next to a candidate's name that makes it
so toxic
let's ask reuben gallego he's a
congressman from arizona he
was asked how his democrats could do a
better job connecting to latinos
he said first start by not using the
term latinx
which the vast majority of latinos have
never heard of and when they do
don't like it who likes it pandering
white politicians
who mistake twitter for real people and
don't get it that latinx is like
fetch you can try to make it happen but
it's never gonna
virginia congresswoman abigail
spanberger said after the election if we
are classifying tuesday as a success we
will get
[ __ ] torn apart in 2022. that's a
congresswoman
she was urging members not to talk about
defunding the police
james clyburn agreed defund the police
is killing
our party he said
pennsylvania democrat conor lamb says
democratic rhetoric
needs to be dialed back it needs to be
rooted in common sense
thank you thank you
there in my opinion is the crux of the
problem
democrats too often don't come across as
having
common sense to a huge swath of
americans
yeah you're right bill democrats often
come off as not having common sense and
i would argue at this point the ship has
sailed
and there are virtually no democrats
that have common sense and this is the
split
between the liberals and the lefties
about forever if you're a same liberal
what policy is it have or what
public person do they have out there
pushing for those same policies just in
the last two weeks
since the president-elect biden
transition team has come in
they're talking about putting critical
race theory
back in the federal institutions it's
coming back if he becomes president that
is the most
anti-liberal set of ideas that we're
going to focus on people's race more
than anything else that you could
possibly imagine
they are putting title ix back in so due
process
on college campuses will be gone all of
the
economic stuff that we're just going to
tax the hell out of people
just because we feel like it so we can
have more government programs so that
does sound like a very lefty thing but
it's a
liberal idea because you want the market
to do as much as possible
now they're saying that they're going to
do 15 minimum wage by executive action i
mean i think that's how the government
works but
nothing questions that watch my show
obviously it's like what makes you a
liberal at this point
you in effect you're a conservative as i
have been saying
forever defending my list is becoming a
conservative position if you care about
free speech which is what i think bill
cares about most
free speech and free expression that
used to be a liberal value not
anymore and when you couple that with
big tech and the story that i'm about to
do in a moment where the
the biden transition guy is literally
calling for free speech to be to be
changed
um you will understand that there is
nothing left it isn't to say that there
aren't decent democrats of course there
are but the leadership has been
absolutely if you think chuck schumer
and nancy pelosi are somehow the
moderates that can stand up
to aoc invite and everyone else like uh
and ill on omar and the rest of them
like you're you're really wrong and
biden of course can't stand up to
anything because once
once he's installed that's the word that
chuck schumer says biden is installed as
president
we're never going to see biden again
biden isn't going to be running this
thing they're going to have
biden has dementia and they're going to
basically hide him in a basement until
one day they admit it and then
and then kamala will be president i
don't even think that's like crazy
conspiracy stuff
to be talking about like i think most
people kind of think that
but if you say it they'll tell you
you're you're a crazy conspiracy theory
but the the fundamental difference that
i have with maher is that he seems to
think and i would say there's a few
somewhat sane liberals that seem to
think we can still save the democrats we
can still
save the left something like that even
though there's no evidence of it we can
see all of the bad ideas getting
strengthened
and on the right it's like sure you
you come over here we'll we'll talk to
you we'll agree to disagree
oh so you're pro-choice we're pro-life
what happens or will accept you
will fully accept you someone like rudy
giuliani who was for gay marriage years
ago and and
is pro-choice right me will accept you
so there's a lot of room over here and
there's no room over here
and i think you know this endless
pretending
that that there's anything left on the
left or that the democrats are ever
going to be decent or get rid of these
bad ideas or that
or that the decent people have any
energy
or that biden was the thing that was
going to stop the lunacy
it's all rushing in right now you can
feel it you can feel all of the bad
things that wokism brings
you can feel them getting strength right
now because they're empowered in many
ways you could actually
connect that to the antifa guys feeling
empowered right now because they're just
like oh well
once biden's in charge we could do
whatever we want because trump at least
was going to threaten to do some things
and threaten to send in
feds in some of these ridiculous cities
but we know biden won't do that
so all of the bad ideas and the bad
actors are being emboldened right now
and and i hope that for whatev whichever
bill maher producer is watching this
because i know you guys do watch the
show
um i hope that you understand that i
would love to have this conversation
with him this is not a knock on him i
think i think
we in many ways saw the world a very
similar way and i think what i'm talking
about
and and the sort of the sort of death of
liberalism and how
liberalism can be saved by conservatism
i think that's the future here
he seems to think this can be saved you
want to talk about it we could do it on
my show you could do it on your show
but i mean in a certain way i don't even
care anymore but i'm just putting it out
there there we go
but let's talk about one other thing
which kind of loops this whole thing
together there was a washington post
op-ed written last year by richard
stengel he's a former obama
administration official and he was i
believe the editor in
uh the editor of time magazine and uh
he wrote a piece about putting limits
on free speech he is now in the biden
transition team so
when i talk about the fact that these
bad ideas of critical race theory of the
attacks on the first amendment the
attacks on the second amendment
um you know getting rid of due process
when i talk about these things they're
not just ideas that we're talking about
like oh well it doesn't matter if these
things exist or not like nothing will
ever change
well now you've got people that are in
charge of the biden transition
if he is to transition into presidency
different type of transition if he is to
do that though
there are people who have literally
written op-eds on changing the first
amendment and changing what the very
definition of free speech in an american
context is
so this is a piece in the washington
post and i'm going to read about a
paragraph here
this is from last year it's an opinion
piece by richard stengel
who was a public diplomacy uh
expert under the obama administration
quote
hate speech has less violent but nearly
as damaging impact in another way
it diminishes tolerance it enables
discrimination
isn't that by definition speech that
undermines the values that the first
amendment was designed to protect
fairness due process equality before the
law
why shouldn't the states experiment with
their own version of hate speech
statutes to penalize such speech that
deliberately insults people based on
religion
race ethnicity and sexual orientation
well goodbye comedians and let's cancel
everybody
from don rickles to george carlin and
there's no funny comedians anymore but
you see the point oh so we should get
rid of the first amendment
right and we should just leave it up to
the states and the states can decide
who you're allowed to offend now in many
ways
i'm guessing that this very issue is one
of the things that drove you to this
show because you know years ago
when when jordan peterson was just
catching fire online
uh one of the issues that that sort of
put him to the forefront was they were
going to try to pass an ordinance in
canada
that you would be able to be penalized
by law
if you misgendered someone meaning if
you were walking down the street and you
said good day ma'am and it turned out to
be a guy and you maybe even did it
unintentionally
that you could be penalized in some way
now as jordan said a million times
and as i will say a million times
respect for trans people
if you choose to to make that transition
that's all well and good
but you can't force me to have compelled
speech to use a pronoun or anything else
but if you treat me with respect i'll
treat you with respect
this is this is all basic stuff that
we've all been through a million times
before
but the idea that the government could
come in and say you misgendered that
person or you made a bad joke
about that group of people or the rest
of it that
is completely counter to the first
amendment which is why he's saying in
effect let's get rid of the first
amendment
but it's anti-american you know our
ability to talk things out
and to joke about things it's one of the
great things that we have and i
i promise you guys i get so much email
about this that
people in other countries that don't
have the first amendment virtually every
country in the world that doesn't have
the protections
of around free speech that we do they
are shocked
they are shocked that we even entertain
these ridiculous
ideas and again this is why i'm bringing
up this story although this is an op-ed
from a year ago
this person is now involved in the biden
administration in the in the transition
if it is to happen this is a real
problem because they will come after
because in effect what they'll do is
they'll say oh see half of the country
those 71 million trump supporting white
supremacists
well should they have free speech what
does that mean should they be allowed to
go to the bank
should they allow to be on twitter
should they have allowed to
open restaurants or everything else and
then when you throw in cobin on top of
it where it'll be those are the people
who are for opening up the country and
they're spreading the disease
and we're the good people we stay at
home we don't spread the disease we
watch what we say
we bow to the leader like that is where
we're gonna end
up with all of this craziness and
i think you just need to be thinking
about it
you know like think about the big
picture stuff not necessarily the
day-to-day political machinations
because something
something strange is going on here and
we got to keep fighting it and i'm going
to keep fighting it and i hope you keep
fighting it and i think i we can win i
don't know what win means like i don't
know if win means an election
or win means some sort of ideological
battle in in the long term or anything
else but
we we got a lot of work to do so anyway
i hope i gave you something that gives
you a little something to work with in
your own world today
i've got a busy day of interviews and a
bunch of stuff coming ahead
and uh have a good day everybody get out
there
breathe take a walk walk your dog walk
your cat walk your turtle people
all right see you tomorrow
you